[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vie pour
aujourd'hui j'ai la le grand plaisir de
recevoir Xavier de Lausanne qui est un
réalisateur documentaire liste
Versailles nous sommes en direct du
Cyrano pour l'avant-première de son film
en toute liberté
Lausanne documentariste
versaillais vous avez une certaine
originaire de Versailles
de vos masques
qui s'appelle à l'ouest production c'est
pour ça que ça m'ennuie que je vous
appelle il y a le François là
ça me dérange pas du tout alors du coup
là on est là pour votre votre film
documentaire là qui va sortir le 8 mars
et en fait vous êtes l'auteur d'une
trilogie documentaire qui a pour thème
la vie après daige on s'était vu
justement en 2020 pour 9 jours à RACA
c'était vous racontez l'histoire de beau
de comme ça oui alors déjà la trilogie
Le comtesse de la trilogie c'est le
trilogie trilogie pardon sur la
je vais y arriver cela reconstruction du
lien social après la guerre à travers
trois expériences voilà trois points de
vue
politique voilà un point de vue
médiatique et un point de vue culturel
et éducatif voilà qui sont pour moi les
trois trois piliers de la reconstruction
voilà oui on a besoin du politique du
média et de la culture et l'éducation
voilà c'était la politique voilà c'est
le premier volet où j'ai suivi une
journaliste qui s'appelle marine de
Tilly et qui est parti à la rencontre de
Leila Mustapha qui est la mère de RACA
alors vous savez Raqqa c'est l'ancienne
capitale de l'État islamique c'est de
racailles où on était comme indiqué les
attentats de Paris quand même et en fait
personne ne pouvait imaginer que tout de
suite à après la Libération après la
chute du régime islamique il allait
avoir une jeune femme de 30 ans qui
allait prendre la tête de cette ville
voilà donc on a été la rencontrer
ensemble et Marine a écrit un livre qui
s'appelle la femme la ville la liberté
chez Stock et puis moi j'ai fait un film
un documentaire pour le cinéma qui est
sorti l'année dernière voilà ça c'est le
premier volet voilà donc là on va voir
ce soir le second donc là en toute
liberté une radio pour la paix vous avez
filmé cette journaliste qui sont de
trois confections différentes musulmans
Yeezy chrétiens ils sont à côté de
Mossoul racontez-moi un peu comment vous
les avez trouvé déjà que qu'est-ce que
ça représente dans la trilogie ce
documentaire alors donc ça c'est le
point de vue médiatique et radio El
Salam c'est une radio qui a été créée en
2015 par un collectif de d'organisation
française et qui a été créé pour pour
faire du lien notamment dans un premier
temps entre les réfugiés c'est à dire
que en 2015
les états islamique était présent dans
toute la plaine de Ninive autour de
Mossoul et à Mossoul et donc du coup il
y avait beaucoup de gens qui fuyaient il
y a tout un ensemble de camps de
réfugiés qui se sont installés dans tout
le nord de l'Irak et donc cette radio a
été créée à Erbil et airby c'est la
capitale du Kurdistan irakien qui se
retrouve à peu près à 60 km de Mossoul
et pour permettre de recréer des
connexions entre les familles parce que
c'est des gens qui ont fui dans très
soudainement souvent et qui ont été
séparés les uns des autres donc cette
radio a été faite pour recréer des
connexions et pour aussi donner la
parole parce que c'est des gens qui ont
été traumatisés et donc la parole est
toujours libératoire et essayer de
donner la parole à ces gens-là
c'est cette journaliste plutôt plutôt
jeune journaliste qui vont donc enquêter
qui font des reportages qui sur une dans
une ville complètement ruine qui dans un
camp de réfugiés etc et je trouve ça
donne comme une sorte de patchwork de
plusieurs situations différentes qui
existent qui se côtoient alors on parle
on a l'impression que le but de cette
radio c'est de rétablir le vivre
ensemble
l'entente entre toutes ces communautés
qui avant daesh s'entendait très bien
arrêtez moi si je me trompe et alors le
fait de qui ait eu daesh qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que pourquoi ça s'est arrêté
cette entente pourquoi c'est si
inquiétant pour eux alors en fait déjà
la société irakienne c'est une société
qui est composée d'une mosaïque de
communauté de mosaïque de peuples avec
tout un ensemble de de confessions de
croyances de langues etc donc c'est une
société très riche où la question de la
mixité sociale fait véritablement partie
de l'ADN
toujours existé et donc toutes ces
communautés là ont toujours été habitués
à vivre pas forcément complètement
ensemble mais en tout cas les unes à
côté des autres et sans que forcément ce
soit l'entente cordiales tout le temps
c'était naturel en tout cas de ce que
toioyer de s'inviter pendant les fêtes
de famille etc et ça ça volé en éclat
déjà ça allait pas très bien sous le
régime de Saddam Hussein ça s'est empiré
au moment de la vision américaine et
puis ça c'est complètement les Torré
évidemment avec la guerre et la présence
de daesh donc concrètement c'est dû à
quoi les gens se sont mis à se détester
en fait c'était malheureux parce que
parce que les ressorts les ressorts de
la guerre ce sont toujours les mêmes et
les ressort de ceux qui veulent asseoir
leur pouvoir donc qui organisent la
guerre qui initient la guerre c'est de
diviser diviser pour mieux régner ça
c'est d'une simplicité enfantine et
pourtant c'est toujours la même recette
pour toutes les guerres et ça évidemment
fonctionné donc
avait commencé à diviser sa propre
société les Américains ont détricoté
toute la structure de la société
américaine et ce qui a ce qui a provoqué
la naissance et l'extension de daesh qui
était préparé pour quoi oui oui le
terrain a été préparé pour et puis le
ressort de daesh ça a été évident
absolument terrible et de de diviser
l'intégralement la société pour des
réseaux purement politique et
idéologiques
les personnes qui témoignent accusent
beaucoup les médias en disant qu'il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de différentes chaînes
de télévision qui manipulent les gens
qui qui intoxiquent avec des propos
complètement galvaudés alors
en fait ce qu'on voit c'est que moi j'ai
suivi cette jeune journaliste qui sont
des jeunes jeunesse qui ont vécu ces
événements qui ont vécu la guerre mais
qui aujourd'hui
sont dé en quelque sorte d'une envie de
reconstruire d'une envie de recréer du
lien d'une envie d'aller de l'avant quoi
et de voir les choses un petit peu
positivement donc ils vont à la
rencontre et je les suis je suis
derrière eux et ils vont à la rencontre
des gens pour les interviews des gens de
toutes origines de toutes confession
religieuse et de toute conviction
politique et il les interroge et en fait
ce qu'on peut voir c'est que beaucoup de
gens disent mais nous on n'a pas voulu
cette guerre on était habitué à vivre
ensemble on n'a pas voulu en fait ces
divisions ceux qui l'ont voulu c'est les
politiques c'est ceux qui ont organisé
ces guerres mais c'est pas nous et en
plus effectivement il y en a un qui
apportent un témoignage sur sur les
médias en disant mais les médias
jettent de lui sur le feu aussi au lieu
de reconnecter ont tendance à monter en
épingle et à créer des hystéries
collectives plutôt qu'à recréer des
liens voilà
et gouvernement derrière les médias
apparemment oui alors c'est pas c'est
pas une accusation on va dire une
personne oui oui ça témoignage d'une
personne en tout cas le politique les
voyages de plusieurs personnes qui sont
plusieurs à dire à pointer du doigt les
politiques en disant c'est leur
responsabilité c'est pas forcément la
nôtre voilà et le c'est pour ça aussi
que moi j'ai voulu faire cette trilogie
et notamment ce film c'est parce que
nous on est on reçoit des images de
guerre aussi en permanence alors la
guerre il faut la documenter il faut la
nuancer la violence il faut parfois la
montrer et il faut aussi la violoncer
mais si on met rien en face je sais pas
trop ce que c'est à part une certaine
forme d'instrumentalisation de la
violence à des profits plus ou moins
mercantils quoi de voyeurisme de
divertissement et donc la frontière elle
est un peu mince parfois et euh
qui m'a en fait mobilisé qui m'a motivé
à aller voir là où les projecteurs
n'étaient plus c'est à dire que on
documente une guerre mais une fois que
la guerre est terminée en fait on se
retire on part et puis on va aller sur
le terrain d'une autre guerre bah oui
enfin la vie ne s'arrête pas une fois
que la guerre s'arrête heureusement et
si après la guerre ou les choses se sont
véritablement intéressantes
reconstruire la paix c'est d'une
difficulté extrême quoi il y a des
enjeux qui sont extrêmement puissants et
c'est très dur c'est pas si difficile de
lancer une guerre par contre te lancer
un processus de reconstruction de
réconciliation de pacification ça c'est
compliqué et alors c'est là où les
choses sont véritablement intéressantes
vous avez des la foyer d'histoire qui
soit absolument passionnantes mais les
caméras sont plus là
donc voilà j'ai voulu aller sur sur ces
terres là en plus l'Irak et la Syrie on
en a entendu parler pendant des années
comme on entend parler aujourd'hui de
l'Ukraine et donc ça me semblait
intéressant de voir quand même ce qui se
passe et dans quelle mesure avec ces
trois piliers politiques médiatiques et
culturelles et éducatif on pouvait
essayer de repenser une société et
repenser un pays et alors dites moi vous
avez filmé quand
de 2018 c'est à dire juste un an à peine
un an après la libération de Mossoul de
2018 jusqu'à 2021 d'accord ok et donc
bah oui c'est ce que je me disais c'est
qu'en fait vous avez le don pour trouver
quand même des petits miracles
d'humanité dans des dans des endroits
très chaotiques ou tout devrait être le
pire au monde et finalement il y a enfin
ça donne de l'espoir tout de même de
voir qu'il y a encore des gens de bonne
volonté on voit les bénévoles on voit
les gens qui ont envie de qui disent aux
chrétiens mais revenez vous aurez encore
votre maison
en fait on voit on voit des ruines mais
on voit que dans ces ruines la vie
continue voilà et que vous avez des gens
déjà qui vous accueillent très très
gentiment même s'ils ont vécu des choses
terribles et qui espèrent toujours et
effectivement vous citer ce monsieur qui
a été le premier à l'un des premiers à
reconstruire sa maison à partir et le
premier à revenir et qui a qui a
retrouvé sa maison et qu'il a 20 ans en
violette à l'extérieur et à l'intérieur
ce qu'il montre en fait un élan de vie
chez cet homme qui retrouve sa terre sa
terre natale et à laquelle il est
extrêmement attaché et il est même on le
filme en haut de sa maison il est
vraiment au milieu des ruines et il nous
dit mais on n'est pas bien là lui il
voit pas les rues de Tours il voit le
fait d'être connu alors il y a que des
décombres autour on n'est pas bien là et
en fait lui ce qu'il voit c'est sa
maison dans laquelle il habite à nouveau
dans le futur et voilà non non mais
c'est ça qui est magnifique en tout cas
alors le prochain le prochain
documentaire ça va s'appeler
on peut en dire deux trois mots oui bien
sûr c'est le le troisième volet c'est
donc le volet culturel et éducatif et
c'est Monsieur campus en fait j'ai suivi
des étudiants de l'université de Mossoul
alors l'université de Mossoul c'est une
très grande un très grand campus très
grande université qui avait très très
ancienne qui avait en son cœur une
immense bibliothèque qui était
bibliothèque très prestigieuse et
réputée dans toute la région mais cette
bibliothèque a entièrement brûlé sous
daesh et donc j'ai suivi les travaux de
reconstruction de réhabilitation de
cette bibliothèque tout en racontant le
quotidien de 4 étudiants autour de
l'Université de garçon et de filles qui
avaient vécu les années terribles de
daesh de pression de daesh mais qui sont
aujourd'hui très conscients de
l'importance de la culture et
l'éducation en tant que rempart contre
l'expérience contre le totalitarisme
contre le fondamentalisme
l'obscurantisme tout ce qui en isthme
visiblement
pour revenir à en toute liberté on a si
je maintiens justement qui vient
témoigner dans votre film et qui donne
c'est pour revenir sur ce que vous dites
qui donnent le l'importance des mots oui
parle de ça justement oui alors il se
trouve que Sylvain
alors Sylvain Tesson déjà c'était le
c'est lui qui a ouvert l'antenne il a
été à ouvrir l'antenne en 2015 il a
ouvert l'antenne en diffusion d'ailleurs
un message de Jean d'Ormesson et du coup
il était un peu au début de la radio il
était un peu le parrain entre guillemets
de le cœur on va dire de la radio et il
se trouve que moi quand je suis arrivé à
herbille en Irak pour prendre les
premières images j'étais dans son avion
de circonstances et donc du coup j'ai
demandé si je pouvais prendre quelques
images il m'a dit oui et c'est
intéressant parce qu'en même temps et
effectivement il parle de l'importance
des mots dans un processus de
reconstruction c'est l'éducation donc il
donne une clé en fait de lecture sur le
on le voit pas on le voit que au début
du film mais il donne une clé de lecture
sur l'ensemble du film
c'est la voix off et Sophia Aram elle a
bien voulu effectivement nous prêter sa
voix en fait
sur ce projet on a on avait besoin d'un
porte-voix et notamment d'une voie de
radio parce que c'est un film sur la
radio donc d'une voix de radio et on m'a
proposé la voix de Sophia Aram et c'est
intéressant parce que mais elle est
arabophone elle est très connectée sur
les questions de la Syrie et l'Irak elle
est très engagée sur la question des
réfugiés notamment donc elle connaît
très bien les enjeux en fait de cette
région là et donc il était tout à fait
légitime de lui demander de d'intervenir
elle a regardé le film elle dit tout de
suite et elle nous a prêté sa voix vous
avez des nouvelles de ces journalistes
aujourd'hui on est connecté ils savent
que le film sort en France
le 8 mars et ils suivent ça de très près
bien évidemment
[Musique]
cette journaliste tendent leur micro à
ceux qui veulent la paix radio
[Musique]
en toute liberté le 8 mars au cinéma
Xavier de Lausanne un grand
merci film et notamment celui-ci
toujours passionnant et enrichissant et
ça donne de l'espoir vraiment et bah
très bientôt pour le troisième merci
Véronique à très bientôt sur vous merci
au revoir
[Musique]